[Musique]
c'est un lendemain d'élection difficile
pour Dominique englade après un résultat
décevant l'expulsion de la députée
Marie-Claude Nicole et son refus de
prendre la main tendue par la chef pour
revenir au caucus est venu souligner
encore une fois la fragilité de son lit
de chips de plus en plus de voix se lève
pour réclamer le départ de Dominique
Anglade qui dit elle vouloir rester mais
combien de temps pourra-t-elle maintenir
cette position j'en discute avec Jean
D'Amour qui était député ministre
président du Parti libéral du Québec que
l'on retrouve à Rivière-du-Loup monsieur
d'amour merci d'être avec nous
ça fait plaisir parce que c'est bon
qu'est-ce qui se passe exactement
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez de la
situation actuelle
c'est une situation pour le moins
troublante conjoncturel parce qu'on
vient de vivre une agression qui a été
particulièrement difficile pour le Parti
libéral cependant ça va plus loin je
pense qu'à partir du moment où on a le
résultat de l'élection en démocratie on
doit respecter le résultat et se mettre
au travail ça va faire bientôt cinq ans
qu'on a pas siéger l'Assemblée nationale
je pense que le parti aurait avantage à
se préparer pour la reprise des travaux
en chambre le 29 novembre prochain
plutôt que de se chicaner moi j'aime pas
vraiment ce qui se passe présentement
sincèrement d'une part Marie-Claude
nicole est expédié le hors du caucus les
mises de côté carrément il y a des
députés qui sous couvert de l'anonymat
s'exprime alors quand t'as pas le
courage de dire écoutez je suis Monsieur
ou Madame X et voici ce que je pense
comme moi je le fais aujourd'hui j'ai
sincèrement un problème avec ça les
débats existent depuis toujours ou
partie libéral du Québec comme dans tous
les autres partis mais c'est la première
crois qu'on se donne en spectacle comme
ça je trouve ça tout à fait désolant bon
l'expulsion madame Nicole c'est vraiment
la goutte qui a fait déborder le vase
ben oui en ce qui me concerne c'est pas
la première fois on a vécu on a vécu cet
épisode là avec Marie Montpetit il y a
un an à peu près jour pour jour sans
qu'on connaisse véritablement les
raisons aujourd'hui c'est Marie-Claude
Nicole sincèrement là on a 20 on avait
21 députés à l'intérieur du caucus et en
reste 20 maintenant incluant madame
andlade c'est c'est moins c'est moins de
députés que le nombre d'élèves qu'on
retrouve dans une école primaire dans
une école primaire au Québec on aurait
capable de s'entendre ce spectacle là
tout à fait gratuit et déplorable c'est
pas à la hauteur du Parti libéral du
Québec moi je pense qu'on devrait se
concentrer sur nos valeurs de justice
sociale de liberté individuelle
d'économie et qu'on se prépare à
affronter le gouvernement logo qui a 90
députés à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
un travail à faire
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure dans la
présentation le leadership madame
anglaise et montrer du doigt beaucoup
c'est un problème de les c'est un
problème de jugement qu'est-ce que c'est
d'après vous bah écoutez quand on
regarde le résultat de l'élection dans
ma circonscription à moi de
Rivière-du-Loup timisuator on a eu quoi
là 4 5% du vote il y a nécessairement un
problème à quelque part il faut qu'on
parle au monde au Québec il faut qu'on
propose un projet de société et ça c'est
entre les mains de la chef oui les
militants parce que des congrès on doit
se prononcer ça c'est important c'est
incontournable il y a un caucus mais
ultimement il y a une chef qui doit
autour d'elle rallier vous savez gérer
un caucus là c'est un travail de haute
précision et c'est pas donné à tout le
monde et lorsqu'on a 21 députés là
lorsqu'on a 20 député à part soi-même
rallier doit pas être une chose si
compliqué travaillant en équipe c'est
obligatoire c'est c'est optionnel là
c'est pas négociable cette affaire là il
y a nécessairement un problème qui est
ce parti-là a plus de 150 ans d'histoire
c'est un parti qui a fait partie des
grands moments de la vie de l'évolution
du Québec on pense à la Révolution
tranquille on pense à l'exemple le plus
que je peux donner c'est le Plan Nord
avec Jean Charest chacun des chefs a
amené sa valeur ajoutée il fait des
Couillard le fait aussi au niveau de
l'assainissement des finances publiques
aujourd'hui si on pose la question
quelle est notre projet à nous au Québec
qui va en même temps satisfaire la
métropole la capitale les régions je
pense que le résultat de l'élection
parle de lui-même et je pense qu'on est
vu pour une réflexion profonde à ce
moment-ci il y aura nécessairement parce
que ça fait partie des statuts de notre
formation politique invoque de confiance
alors on s'en va vers ça puis faudra se
prononcer comme méditant je vous ai
entendu cette semaine à la radio à
l'émission de mon collègue allait
castongué dire la barre elle est à 90%
pour Madame Anglade sur un vote de
confiance vous vous pensez que ça va
aussi ou que ça je les ai à monsieur
castongué je vous le répète monsieur
Thibault puis en bas en 290%, ça devient
invivable pour un chef puis si on prend
les exemples dans le passé mais si
Bouchard qui était quand même un grand
politicien au Québec avec 76 77% quelque
temps plus tard il le PQ 76% Bernard
Landry on a fait tout autant séance
étonnante il est il a quitté le plancher
du Congrès pendant là à l'intérieur de
ma propre formation politique un homme
pour qui j'ai le plus grand respect la
plus grande admiration Daniel Johnson
avec plus de 80 % quelque temps plus
tard il a fait le choix de quitter vous
savez en deçà de 90 %, ça fait du monde
qui dans les corridors chuchote bavarde
s'exprime un chef pour faire une
campagne électorale a besoin d'un appui
massif quasiment de faire l'unanimité à
l'intérieur de ses propres troupes en
deçà 90% c'est une pensée qui est très
personnelle qui n'engage que moi mais je
ne crois pas que ça puisse tenir la
route c'est un grand défi qui attend
madame à ce moment-ci ça ça c'est la ça
c'est la marque à atteindre dans un vote
de confiance madame anglais elle semble
vouloir rester à la tête du parti
peut-elle se permettre de rester
jusqu'au vote de confiance
c'est un choix qui lui appartient elle
devra au cours des prochaines semaines
se poser une question est-ce que je suis
la personne qui va permettre au Parti
libéral du Québec d'accéder au pouvoir
en 2026 est-ce que je suis la personne
qui est capable de rallier les Québécois
de toute origine et de toutes les
régions du Québec et lorsqu'elle aura
répondu à cette question-là si elle
décide de se soumettre au vote de
confiance ben elle se soumettra pas de
confiance ah mais mais elle a une
question à se poser et c'est nous les
militants parce que moi je suis un
militant j'ai beau avoir été député
ministre et président du parti
aujourd'hui je suis un militant qui aura
à se prononcer et la question pour elle
elle est importante mais la décision
finale c'est nous qui allons l'apprendre
merci infiniment d'avoir été des nôtres